howdy howdy howdy welcome back to M Cube
the inside Trek over here whichever I
can never figure out the fingers and
hands and all that yada yada yada but uh
we've got Cinema scoop Wednesday ready
for you today we we don't have the the
most amount of topics to go over but the
topics we do have to go over are good
ones Tiff just released a bunch of good
movies to come out and we'll we'll talk
about that probably a little more
towards the end but to start this thing
off we are going to be talking about
where big budget movies go to die
or go to get passed on one of the others
it's more clicky to type where to die
but I mean we've got we're going through
immediate thing at the moment when we
went stuff's getting made that then
isn't getting released
ever happened before
yes but not to this degree kind of
Batgirl yeah yeah recent memory is kind
of uh never happened before
not like that not like that well uh
shall we roll This intro and hop in it
go for it let's do it
[Music]
all right all right let me uh grab this
article over here and
free back up
uh oh yeah all right well shall we do
how we did the other day and kind of go
back and forth broke it through yeah
all right so what happened to big budget
TV shows like Nautilus after they are
canceled if y'all remember I think last
Wednesday we talked about the Creator
and rebel moon but the Monday of last
week we talked about
Nautilus and uh what's the other one
that just got can uh Spiderwick
Chronicles Spiderwick Chronicles was uh
I began I believe had begun filming and
it got passed on all right
um yes by the week yeah that thing they
pretty much
I think they've done a fair bit of
filming on it they spent a lot of money
He-Man the live action He-Man got
canceled three weeks before that and
they haven't started principal
photography but they had spent 30
million dollars in development 30
million
yeah one third of Batgirl because that
was 90 million which is insane yeah yeah
yeah it's 80 yeah high 80s wasn't it
that they'd say they'd spent and
principal photography was virtually done
um I actually believe photography was
done wasn't it they were just doing it
and they might have done so they were
planning a couple of reshoots yeah it
needed reshoots and a few other things
that one I think is like that's that's
the it's it's the not the Golden Goose
but the the ugly duckling I think
because that one everyone that saw it
said it was god-awful and and it's like
all right okay well if it's not gonna
make you money and it's gonna hurt your
company
I understand making business decisions
but then seeing all these things
afterwards like Spiderwick Chronicles
and Nautilus
they're still trying to shock them
around so they can't be awful they can't
be things that they're just looking for
a Cuts in but we'll read this article
I'll check Prodigy again that's another
one they've done the same it's a
nautilus is the same the show is
virtually done
they have 10 episodes virtually done
now they're not going to show it it's
just yeah I forgot let's read the
article if that explains it real quick
howdy everybody howdy howdy howdy
nice to see everybody as always but this
is a article on collider by Aiden Bryant
where do all the shows go and what does
that mean for us
so big streamers like Max Netflix and
Disney Plus have been in hot water with
the public for seemingly years now
between Rising rates bad shows in the
ongoing wga and sag after strikes
there's a lot of Goodwill going around
one of the more recent issues to pop up
has been regarding the removal of
content from a lot of these streaming
services for no apparent reason not
because of problematic content or right
right slapsing but simply just to save
money for the studio now this started
with mostly old and cult material like
the majority of the Looney Tunes back
catalog and the show was the Genesis of
Adult Swim Space Ghost Coast to Coast
which is so sad we need more now we're
beginning to see some new moves by the
studios and they're quite troubling
before we jump forward
oh well we're going to get into a couple
of the reasons here and there are more I
think there are more reasons than they
list but we'll talk about it 20
000 Leagues Under the Sea was completely
filmed with extensive sets and a massive
crew only to be completely shelled by
Disney as a cost-cutting measure a big
budget show and it probably was um
wasn't this sort of like in the eight
nine million dollars an episode area I
think yeah they really went all the way
out for 25 I mean 20 000 Leagues Under
the Sea that's what you want them to do
you know another 90 million dollars
under the um thrown away basically yeah
it could have been a big budget show
bigger stream of service out there and
they never even put it out something
isn't right there Max has also started
acting bigger shows with popular sci-fi
series like Westworld being taken off
the service Paramount plus removed John
Peel's version of The Twilight Zone
which was Madness while this is
extremely concerning it offers a few
questions for one why would a stream
service remove content when the point of
streaming has always been the endless
supply of content to Satish it satiate
every type of viewer and when those
shows do not do get removed where do
they go
the one thing is with Netflix they've
always added and removed and brought
back content because it's a way of
actually keeping it fresh they can
release an email for everybody going and
new on Netflix and my wife always gets
confused oh there's a new movie out
because no babe look it's actually 20
years old and what I said no this is new
it's new to Netflix
um you know you keep an eye on that sort
of thing
um but
no but what we haven't seen before is
shows removed when they've only been out
a couple of months or like this a show
that's been made and not released hasn't
even been like promoted yet which is
insanity we I don't think we've ever
seen that before
um sometimes when the show airs back in
the day on a network it would air they
would get maybe to 10 or 12 episodes and
all of a sudden the show would get
canceled and get replaced if something
else that happened would happen quite a
lot but what didn't really ever happen
the only closest we used to get to this
was sometimes a pilot would get made oh
actually that's exactly what I was
reading and they would never see the
light of day or sometimes be sold off to
another Studio to be used elsewhere and
that's that's what they're doing now for
an entire series or multiple series well
the cost of a pilot and the cost of
doing an entire series is completely
different you're talking about a
sometimes even hundreds of thousands of
dollars or a couple of low Millions
compared to
you know but back in the day these shows
didn't used to cost Millions the pilots
would cost 18 19. a couple hundred
thousand dollars really because they
were making loads of them they were like
churning them out so all of this so this
is it's a very strange situation at the
moment
yeah there's a whole different
environment where they'd make a studio
would say all right we're making six
Pilots we expect two maybe three we'd be
lucky if any more went uh it's more like
they're gonna stick with one two is
probably the thing but they're gonna
choose between those two later on uh
which everyone does better on air
that's just not happening now they're
just doing it prior to everything even
being marketed released or even a a a
plan for a marketed release to happen at
all which is funky
um Pilots were always on a shoestring
budget yeah that's true and they're not
necessarily anymore the closest thing in
recent memory that's not like
this year last year or something like
that that I can think of like this was
once again just a pilot but
what was it the um what was the title
was it blood moon or it was a thing yeah
um streamer Services don't tend to do
pilots or do they they don't they don't
tend to not all of them to do 10
episodes
what we tend to see then is network
still do pilots and you can still tell
when a new show comes out the Quantum
Leap was the most recent one that you
could really tell at the first double
episode was a pilot it was cheap as hell
and really doing a shoestring and then
the show really improved as the first
season went on
um when when it got a bit of trust and
they got going
um but that was the last show I can
really remember sitting down and going
whoa that's a that's like a proper old
school pilot you know like a couple of
characters disappeared in the third
episode because they thought we don't
like them let's get rid of them and you
know like that was that was what you you
know you could always tell back in there
couldn't you show you'd have the pilot
then basically for the second episode a
couple of people would disappear a
couple of people would come in sometimes
whole new characters sometimes it'd be
like a completely different character
but the same person with a completely
different actor The A-Team is a perfect
example of that yeah yeah man for the
pilot is a completely different person
they replaced him with Duke Benedict
because he didn't
the audience didn't like him so they
just got rid of him and brought dirt
Benedictine
um
the most recent thing I can think of is
Parks and Recreation they got rid of
Mark brandanowitz after one season
because it just wasn't funny and
you bolster the cast around it after
that fact but
yeah I I can't think of anything else in
recent memory that's a lot of shows you
see changes of like season just after
the start of season two you'll see
changes Star Trek the Next Generation
was was thing on that the um Jordan
laforge who used to be like um one of
the pilots all of us sudden developed
loads of engineering skills and become
chief engineer
um the Klingon yeah wolf became chief of
security which made sense and they
killed off Tasha and that was I think
halfway through the second season and
then the show got a lot better after
that but that's quite common we saw that
in Star getting stuff as well hey
Brinkley yeah
um you know that they they re-jig things
along the way to make things work you
know that's quite common but um yeah the
stream of services don't if a stream of
service isn't sure about something like
this what they tend to do is that
they'll do a special
you'll see a one-off yeah like a
straight to streaming movie or something
and then you might see a series later
they do that sometimes
but which is effective when done right
werewolf by midnight is the thing that
comes to mind uh not so effective we're
not done right guardians of galaxy the
holiday special
um there's no plan for a series after
that what's the book but no I know what
you mean it did set up Guardians three
to a degree it had definite elements
that like if you've watched the holiday
special it helped enhance what you saw
for the Guardians three
ish like it was just just just a tad you
know let's be honest the Christmas
special was crap and Gardens Galaxy
three also great you know speaking of
Kevin Bacon
apparently there's a new series of
trimmers with Kevin Bacon that got
canceled after one episode so that
episode's floating around somewhere if
that is the case no that's true
they did they did try to do a series of
Tremors
um and it got but it didn't get it
didn't get canceled didn't get picked up
okay so it's not quite the same thing
but um but yeah Kevin Bacon they did try
to do a Kevin Bacon Center Tremors
series which just would have just been
I've loved it no trimmers is like the
best B movie it's like an a movie B
movie I don't know how to describe it
it's best yeah it's that there's a
little category of of really properly
classic B movies because it is it's a b
movie yeah and that are a properly
brilliant and it's uh and it's honest I
watch it with my kids quite recently and
they were like this is great who the
hell has this always been it's always
been there it's just waiting for us
right but it was but yeah it wasn't
really because it was it was a quite a
big
um budget for a b movie really the
special effects were pretty good oh yeah
most don't get that kind of
decent film before those B movies don't
end up with
seven plus sequels after the fact anyway
obviously they didn't end up it ended up
being a character right wasn't it birth
that they followed yeah
the guy with the big gun got a couple of
sequels uh a couple he's in all of them
he's the main guy after that yeah he
became the main guy yeah
um yeah
the only thing the only film that I
think that's maybe not like Sharknado
where they bended millions of them yeah
yeah there was a bunch of Sharknado
or anything like that
Lake Placid but yeah uh out of these
that we just saw on this part of the
article though which one are you that
was a little too much highlighting which
which one do you think is the most
surprising because Westworld and
Twilight are insane golden revealed The
Twilight Zone I think that's more of a
film he then releases you see a spike
yeah and and he's only going to be doing
big things
um so I'm surprised by that Westworld
was starting to
it wasn't as the first season was great
but it was starting to to go down so I'm
not surprised by that but um I think
when we go into the next section isn't
Westworld been bought by somebody else
who's going somewhere else somebody will
buy that because somebody will watch it
and I think it'll become a cult classic
at some point I think I think it will be
one of those things that people will
watch
I think those first two seasons are
great the first season's
perfect the second we're right up next
to perfect second season's really really
good next to great
and then it just it just nose Dives I
still haven't seen the forces I think
I'm in an episode I'm I don't even
remember I think I'm an extra in an
episode somewhere in season four of my
old roommate
I'm gonna have to watch that because the
fourth season
um I've watched a bit of it it is
supposed to pick up so I do keep meaning
and watch your building they took it off
so um I don't think it's even on the sky
platform over here though it's supposed
to HBO's defense upon sky sky Atlantis
over here and I've done everything is on
there I kind of think the only I might
be completely wrong but if memory serves
me right I think that the only way to
get it is to buy it right now I think
what
Warner Brothers maybe wants you to do to
a degree well they're going to be sad
because I'm not doing it
I'll wait for it to appear on Roku and
then I'll watch it well speaking of just
nautiluses and things real quick
Flanagan and then made 12 or 13 Pilots
before we took the role in Atlantis that
was a great story I loved that
shuttlepod story there but yeah that
used to happen all the freaking time
that that y'all know that shuttlecock
story that's like the epitome
like Jennifer Aniston did loads and she
did hundreds of these things and um
we saw um oh the other one the other
woman from friends whose name's not gone
in my head uh
sorry Lisa Kudrow
no no the other one uh
Courtney is it Fox I wanna yeah right
feel free to support Courtney Arquette
whatever his middle name was because she
was all kept for a bit wasn't she but
anyway
um Courtney she was she was in loads but
we got you can actually find two in a
few because a few actually made to wear
[Music]
whatever she is now
um but um but but yeah she she got but
yeah they're all they appeared I think
it was only been pretty much like David
Schwimmer that hadn't really
done a lot and they actually they they
wanted him specifically but he hadn't
really I think he'd been on stage and
stuff but he hadn't really done a great
deal so um
but yeah but yeah
that's the way it works yeah no I'm I'm
with you though I think twilight zone is
the the one out of these it's just like
really because part of me is like okay
it might not have the biggest audience
but it has an ageless audience in a way
yeah since it's Jordan peel anybody new
coming on that might be one of the
things that hurts it though is it feels
like kind of Doctor Who in a way we're
like
I I thought all the new Doctor Who stuff
was like really correlative with all the
old stuff until like y'all corrected me
like in the last few months essentially
uh I feel like that might kind of be the
same way with Twilight Zone people are
like oh it's that old show they're still
making it they don't necessarily realize
it's Jordan Peele
uh that would be the only thing but I
think Jordan peeled because before peel
was just that other guy in that comedy
show for a while but now he's actually
becoming a properly
respected director and it's only gonna
go up and all of a sudden if they could
assuming if they could get him to
continue making it and just do like the
bit of the start a bit you know like um
thing he used to do
um Hancock used to do Hitchcock sorry I
used to do yeah and that would only I
would have thought that would you get
you're gonna get a cult following is
going to grow but David's gonna that's
it I just have to wonder what demo what
what information are they using to make
these decisions that's a good point
because they're not sharing it with us
that's the truth and there are reasons
why they're taking this stuff off yeah
and not just so let's let's go on to the
next bit all right all right let's talk
about I think now doesn't it so the
second question is the easiest answer
for a show like Nautilus it's being
shopped around to other streamers and
will hopefully be picked up by someone
if not that's really all she wrote for
the show Westworld wants a huge show for
HBO is not available anywhere currently
unless you want to buy the entire series
all right well we just answered
ourselves rumors had to go into Tubi but
it seems like that is only on their live
Warner Brothers Channel and you cannot
watch the show as it would traditionally
be watched on streaming you can only
watch it whenever it's airing on that
channel Twilight Zone has been booted to
free oh I didn't realize that has been
booted to free the Amazon Prime where
it's only available with ads this is
really the opposite of the promise of
streaming that's true I don't have a
problem with freev though because people
keep moaning that they have to watch
these things and it's behind a paywall
and they have to like I can't afford any
more streaming services
is your wet dream
um 30 second adverts but they tend and
they are irritating because they tend to
be the same one go to the toilet
um what's better about that is they'll
play two or three maybe four or 30
second adverts but it's less time at the
end of the day than what you would be
watching on cable with with ads in
general in fact that constant I'm sure
it probably will get to that point where
the adverts aren't annoying like that
but because it only seem to have three
companies that want to advertise on for
easy most of the adverts are advertising
other shows
um it's but at some point it's going to
grow but yeah I just thought yeah okay
you're saying you want more content but
you don't want to pay another
subscription
freebie you should be that people
probably are people going nutseller I
don't know how much bloody adverts which
Amazon I feel like is already kind of if
you're paying that 10 12 or 15 a month
whatever it is for Amazon Prime you get
a streaming service out of it too like
it's already almost freebie in its own
little way but you don't need to have
Amazon Prime to watch really no yeah
through through your smart TV so I mean
it's it's can be free but um okay
real quick Matt Matt was saying he's
currently too tired from work to even
consider being interesting it's all
right we still love you we still love it
is it called in a boy I'm like 20 years
older than both of you
so
supreme leader for Fox side
how many times have I got to tell you
these things
um I'm gonna get I'm gonna find a way to
do a supreme leader snoke thing like
Star Wars
you can do something I know we're giving
them ideas already
um real quick we'll finish this little
uh paragraph here when the streaming
boom started it was a home for shows
that maybe didn't get enough love to
either be watched by a new audience or
to be revived like what Netflix did with
the rest of development now we're seeing
shows that people did watch and love
were shows that haven't been even aired
yet being removed from streaming
entirely Raised by Wolves which had
release got attached to it was removed
from Max entirely there is seemingly
nothing you can do to stop your show
from being removed
okay I'm Raised by Wolves though I'd as
much as I'm a Sci-Fi fan I hated that
show I never watched season two but it I
I forced myself to finish it and it hurt
I just I couldn't follow it
I couldn't I just like I just couldn't
follow it you know me I love slow Burns
I love conceptual sci-fi the weird stuff
that like all right just bring me along
bring me along until you hit me with it
there was nothing to ever hit me with
there no it just it made no sense to me
I I couldn't follow I did try but I
didn't I didn't get through even a
couple I think I might have watched two
episodes and I just thought I don't know
what's going on and you shouldn't be
watching TV going what's going on it's
not an essay it's not like you're doing
a levels it's supposed to be
entertainment and it just wasn't it was
it went they went it just no it wasn't
entertainment it was just it was just
silly yeah and I I saw Ridley Scott and
my brain was like just finish it oh it's
really Scott it'll be good it'll be good
and it just never was it just it was it
made me more sad than alien Covenant I'm
kidding it made me more sad than
Prometheus
yeah both not great
foundations are slow burn but it's it's
meticulously beautiful along the way and
Raised by Wolves was Barren and boring I
just don't know another way to say it
and then even though I agree Foundation
is a slow burn it's slow burn with a
with a point yes and
um
and yeah if that's not your thing go
watch Star Trek because that's not you
know that's just like
every five seconds something go watch
that
um
yeah or Stargate I'll go back to Target
just do what I did yesterday turn off
Wheel of Time and put Stargate Atlantis
on I'm 150 now I'm a very happy boy
um but you know it's just like
just just just watch something else if
that's not your thing then fine but if
you want something that does make you
think and does you know
is a bit intellectual as well but it's
conceptual and things then yeah
definitely 100 and I feel like raised
raised by wolves is probably some of
those things more so in season two but I
don't need to watch an entire season of
a show to get
to something it's something what's going
on with that it was over my head yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean there's something
but it's just like okay we'll piece
these things together just
a little not necessarily a whole lot
faster but just give us yeah
with with this though I really like the
second part of that article because it
said uh Arrested Development was brought
back by Netflix and they've done that I
think two or three times with Arrested
Development
shit's creek
they made that into a massive hit oh
yeah they've done that a few times and I
guess that's probably the closest thing
that we will have seen in recent memory
to
correlate to what's going on now but
this is I mean the difference is like
these shows have never aired and yeah
we've covered that but
how do you sell something that hasn't
aired how do you sell something that
doesn't have a baked in audience I guess
20 000 Leagues Under the Sea has a baked
an audience and so does Spiderwick
Chronicles
but some of these other shows that might
be on The Cutting Board
how do they get picked up but I think a
few years ago for show it may be not
done very well on the network it
appeared on stream and service
they they would still try and get some
of the money back you know I mean they
would still try and it's back in the day
it'll be like if a film is bombed at the
cinema it would be on a DVD within a
couple of weeks it would be or if they
just realized during testing or whatever
this film is not very good this hasn't
worked it would just go straight to DVD
that still happens now we still get
films that we are expecting to go to
cinema and then very last minute it's on
Hulu you know what I mean it's like this
does happen
um but afraid but obviously prey was
meant for Hulu it just felt like it
should he was always supposed to be but
they spoke they did speak about Cinema a
couple of months before there was rumors
that or maybe this should go to the
cinema and then the the rumor is that
the sequel will go to the cinema
um hopefully Blue Beetle doesn't hurt
those chances because Blue Beetle was
supposed to be a TV movie and then they
were like ah we'll toss it in theaters
look how good prey did on Hulu
um blue Beetle's not doing too great
it's because prey was good yeah I
thought just hope they don't ruin that
by because there's been lots of
conversations about maybe Arnie would be
in it and he would bring back Duke um
not Duke that's all right is it
what's his character's name is it is it
not Duke Duke sounds I don't know that
just sounds right for every Arnie
character honestly uh he will be back um
so
um but I think that would be a massive
mistake I also think there's those
rumors that she's gonna be
um becoming a because in the comics and
stuff if somebody survives a battle with
um a predator they can go on and then
actually fight alongside the Predators I
kind of hope they don't do that
um because that would be I'm not sure
about that
um I like the idea and like the cultural
stuff it just turns into a cheese fest
too quickly I feel like it's to get a
sequel to play right is going to be I
think what they actually have to do is
do a prey movie pray to but completely
different characters in a different time
frame or something that could work
and follow her character uh they better
have something very clever in mind
yeah now I I because I really like the
cultural bit of the the yacht is the
yacha yacha I think is how you say it
something like that and how the the
Predator is the easiest way to say it uh
they incorporate those like the best
warriors they find across the world
across galaxies into their Fleet into
their yeah that was them that was
revealed in requiem
um and then the the Predator
um that actually they use the
um genetic material from their prey to
improve themselves so they're constantly
evolving which is why we then in the
Predator we see that massive like nine
foot Predator because it's in the next
gen we saw that in Predators as well
that um it was
there was like a lower class Predator
that was born up something so I'm there
that hierarchy so we've seen that before
um but but yeah it was nice to see like
the an earlier version of The Predator
which a lot of people went nuts over I
mean a lot of people went uh 90 pound
girl can't beat up a predator and I was
like actually the point in that film all
the way through really annoyed me the
point in that film all the way through
was that actually that the Predator
doesn't consider a threat and that's how
she arrives early on but she survives
just long enough to watch and to figure
out a way of actually defeating the
predator and actually Arnie's muscles
didn't matter because the Predator was
much bigger than him and much stronger
than him it was his intelligence that he
was lucky enough to last for whatever
reason Dutch it was Dutch yep yep yep
I'm gonna say it in a little bit he was
lucky enough to be last because the
competitor could have killed him first
and he'd been dead nothing he'd done if
he was the guy you know with the um with
the the midi gun sort of thing and he
just gets shot
at that point it's either Jesse Ventura
or Carl Weathers movie yeah I mean yeah
exactly but if if it had been Dutch
could have been killed first and he
wouldn't know it was coming he just
happened to be lucky enough to be last
and
um and happened to be I happened to have
been a scouter when he was a kid other
than that
he was just lucky yeah
it was the same formula it didn't matter
that she was a 90 pound girl that's just
the locusts going nuts for real I I
don't think there's a single Predator
movie whether it's one of the good ones
or one of the bad ones or one of the
middling ones that has a human being
just straight up punching and trying to
fight a a yacha a predator there's not a
feasible way whether you're irony or
whether you're
um Amber mid Thunder in the 1800s as a
Native American frolicking with hatchets
and arrows like
no matter what you got to use physics
against them things and you got to be
able to be smart and that's what they
did the ax on the bungee I I'm gonna go
it looked great but come on
genius yeah and the flowers that make
you dead that's not stupid but I I
didn't I didn't mind I could let that go
because other stuff was brilliant and
the bear scene when the Predator killed
the bear was just brilliant that was
great but I guess the the stuff with the
accent stuff it never never
suspended our disbelief I guess it it we
still remember
it was a bit like Captain America's
shield yeah Daredevil with his sticks
Banks
it's you know is that it was just this
side of okay we all know that Captain
America's shield defies physics but we
ignore it because it looks cool and it's
just this side is stupid and that was
the with the axes really it's like yeah
it's movie
but yeah it's but it's a movie yeah
exactly you're gonna have a bit if all
movies were 100 realistic sick I'm born
without me
yeah about a chick fighting an alien as
well by the way so I think we can let
the ax go we uh were we talking about it
yesterday or the day before like sound
of freedom and all these different
movies right now like
it's it's doing a lot better than a lot
of movies but I would be very sad if
every movie was as real or sound of
freedom is
it'd be depressing as hell I wouldn't go
to the movies 150 times a year right
like I just I wouldn't uh but if we get
prey we get Avengers we get some Star
Wars obviously I'm naming like IPS right
now but if we just get creative fun
little projects like the Creator or or
Rebel Moon even something like that
I know that people have maybe got a bit
sick of I know we'll talk about this
yesterday and people got a bit sick of
maybe the extraordinary and the overuse
of CGI and all this sort of things we've
talked about which is just
I I'm all right with if you're a CGI but
there are certain films if you can't do
it in real life don't bloody do it
um
not fast and the furious that's a bad
example because they just go ridiculous
um I'm gonna drive a car through a
satellite hey
um
one in 60 seconds right so most of that
movie is actually done and a lot of it
is the actors actually driving the cars
and you know like Nick Cage is actually
really good driving does a lot of the
stunts but there is a stunt at the end
when he jumps the Shelby
um on a bridge and it's a it's a
suspension bridge and it is done with
um special effects CGI and they actually
said look they were really really wanted
to do it in real life
but the stunt coordinate said if we go
an inch wrong you're going to hit those
cables and it will slice the car into a
million pieces kill everyone potentially
collapse a bridge
maybe we do with special effects and I'm
just like okay fine and it was done
subtly though it wasn't like you know
they didn't do a backflip or anything it
didn't do a million rolls and then Banks
over the hero it just did a jump
and something wasn't safe to do in real
life they did it with some special the
problem is the thing is I think we've
got so used to things like Fast and the
Furious which just goes it's just gone
it's stupid well it's still weird where
you can be watching an Avengers movie
and like literally
80 of what you're watching is a cartoon
eighty percent of what you're watching
the CD guy and and a lot of the time it
looks really good but then it takes you
out of it a lot of the time too and but
when you apply that to something that's
not like as Fantastical you toss Fast
and Furious in there the the last two
movies I think
they're my I love me some fast and
furious yeah
oh that's my favorite popcorn
and then the ninth movie came out and
then FX came out or fast 10 whatever the
hell it is
um
there's a suspension bridge collapsing
so he jumps the car and he catches the
wheel on the wire as it and then it
swings him over and he lands the other
side and I'm just like come on you you
tell me
Dominic Toretto has the the
comprehension of physics to be able to
do that on the go in the middle like I
don't no no no no no no no no no
even if you did it still wouldn't work
the wheel would be ripped off yeah but
there's what I'm saying is this I I've
we've argued this with the Transformers
movies a couple of times as well I play
a fun game with my kids how many times
will they start 100 have died and it's
like um and my five-year-old daughter's
actually going I think if that would
have um shattered his back Daddy because
yes honey it would have done yes
and there's there's suspending disbelief
and there's just being this is stupid
and you can get away with one or two
stupid moments you're like oh that was a
bit silly but what a movie but when it's
like every two or three minutes you're
like I want a quarter of your film is
just silly and it's not like it's not
silly we're
silly works sometimes Guardians of the
Galaxy it works something like that it
works but even then it can be very
tiring at times it's literally by the
third Guardians it was kind of like all
right all right now we're gonna lean
into sadness because if we've kind of
leaned a little too far into silliness
um we're gonna lean into sadness but no
one's gonna die yeah
which is silly like
Galaxy three but anyway let's get into
the next bit because this is the bit
where we start talking about why is it
actually happening it let's do it let's
do it you want to read or you want me to
I'll read it yeah it's fine
um
this goes into the elephant in the room
why a stream is removing this content in
the first place there is no issue with
the content itself well sometimes there
is I just agree with that but popular
people and properties are attached to
them and to reiterate a wealth of
content is the entire point of streaming
you would think like Jordan Pino's a
twilight zone is something right for
reevaluation or at least a bump in view
is when he releases a new film which we
mentioned earlier yet that is never
going to happen now Disney has
reportedly said that gutting a big
portion of his content
um it's part of 1.5 billion dollar cost
cutting measure this content
disappearing coinciding with the current
battle over residuals is the ongoing
strikes is something that cannot be
overlooked if the writers and actors
manage to win all we have to then do is
the streamers just cut more and more
content in retaliation I don't agree
with most of that
now it's just stuck in my son has just
text me
there is a residuals issue here but
actually one of the biggest cost cutting
measures
just a second let me speak to my idiot
son no of course um okay so I'm
I'm worth you I don't necessarily agree
with it cost cutting measures do take up
a lot of the things that like
could be could be the reason these
things are happening but I mean the
guardian of content is
I don't necessarily think it's it's as
much of a it is a cost cutting measure
there's not a really I guess a way to
say it besides that it is a cost cutting
measure but I think it's a cost cutting
measure for quantity over quality I
think they are figuring it out that hey
if we want something we want it good and
maybe maybe one of the good things about
all this like I think a comment uh I did
see it earlier was a fantastic comment
was oh I'll find it I'll find it
um
one thing that's hurting the strike is
that we can now go watch the shows we
wanted to watch before but didn't have
time
there's so much so many projects so much
content that we still have time to catch
up on that
I think the studios are yeah they're
doing some cross-cutting measures
they're looking at these things and
saying we can't do what we have been
doing and then they're looking at us who
still have
in numerous numbers of things to keep
watching and keep ourselves entertained
while these creators are not creating
anything else
what's I think the their thought process
hopefully at least from this is that
maybe we need to make less less projects
and make more pertinent projects
per thing and that's what I hope is
happening with all this that's that's my
optimistic view of all these things
shuffling around people canceling things
trying to sell them elsewhere
I hope this is just adding pertinence
again to a lot of the things that we
watch if that makes sense but that
doesn't follow through with things like
normal Solace though that I could
understand that with more removing stuff
that's been on there a while like
Netflix does we're going to when Netflix
first came along it was a bunch of old
shows with with the odd new thing
Netflix would make the odd thing here
and there
um and it still is really it's mostly
old stuff that they've repackaged or you
know and think with a few new shows
thrown in it and they rotate it
constantly they're constantly taking
films off and constantly putting other
things on
this isn't what we're seeing at the
moment though this is actually them
spending 100 million dollars in a
nautilus series and then saying you know
what let's not put it on
now there is rituals thing I was saying
before my son so rudely found me two or
three times
um
oh he's good no he just wants to stay
out late and I've just sent it to school
nights and he's got to be back by about
eight and he's like hey hey I guess
you're 14 years old and it's a school
night get back but give a maid 45.
no I was a bad kid don't answer don't
listen to me but uh so
um
but he hasn't only two on infants but
anyway it's irrelevant
um so it's residuals is a point but at
the moment one of the reasons why The
Strokes a strike is going on is that the
actual streaming services are not that
good at paying residuals and what they
do pay tends to be [__] so the residuals
really I don't think is a big part of it
residuals for a show that hasn't even
aired yet
they don't know how successful that show
is going to be and a lot of the
residuals is based on how much it's
watched so if a show is getting watched
you pay the residuals if it isn't if no
one's watching it you don't pay the
residuals that's not a reason what is a
reason
is that all of these shows have to be
sat on servers somewhere so there are
computer banks have to hold all of these
shows and it is horrendously expensive
and it's only become more expensive
Netflix didn't pay
you know I paid a couple of Pence on the
dollar 10 years ago because they were
the only ones in the shop they were the
only ones doing it so you know renting
the space on servers around the world
and okay it's not just one they have to
do it in several plate locations wasn't
too bad but now there are lots of
streaming services all of a sudden
they charge a lot more
um Amazon are making a killing on this
because they're one of the companies
that are creating a lot of these
streamer Services it's one of the most
profitable areas of their business
um it's you know it's like
so that is the main reason why when they
when Disney took a load of stuff off a
few months ago they had an instant
saving of 600 million dollars
and when the company is really
struggling and a lot of making massive
losses all of a sudden is you look at
everything that's on your screen say if
something's not being watched get it off
yeah it's just costing us money just
sitting there
well it's like essentially it's it's
online real estate in a lot of ways
they're having to pay taxes on it one
way or another taxes on it one way or
another and if you're not getting
something to pay off those taxes with
you'd probably rather not pay them but
it's like having rental it's like having
a house that no one's living there and
you just but you're paying rent on it
yeah it's just not there so get rid of
it
um and that's what they've done with a
lot of these shows is they've just said
right okay for something watch it but
bummer's gotta go because we need the
space and it's expensive
um so I mean I know Disney have saved a
crap load of money through just freeing
up space on the service and and renting
less of it
um and you know and and Netflix have
been doing the same for a while but
they've managed it pretty well that's
why they that's why stuff goes off
that's why TV shows go off there
um well but again that doesn't really
understand why they've got rid of this
Nautilus because that might have been a
massive hit unless they think it's not
okay so that I was gonna ask you
if they were doing this a year ago
do you think Willow ever makes it to TV
if they have the same mindset they do
then do you think the reason Nautilus
and Spiderwick Chronicles got canceled
is because they thought it was on par or
worse than Willow or do you think
they're just doing it just for cost
cutting measures and they're like all
right well this isn't what we want to
present ourselves as so
we made it but we want to sell it to
somebody else there's a couple of things
as well
two uh 12 months ago a lot of the stream
improved like the studio sorry had
um Executives in charge of inclusion
inclusionism inclusionist exactly and
those those have started to get fired
basically it's time to get rid of a lot
of them they've realized that
um I think you know I hate the term work
I hate it
um but that's the word we have to use
now it's as simple as that
there are bigots and stuff that chat
woke we say this all the time but
actually there are there is there is a
problem there that we've had some TV
shows that are so
the inclusionism is is on their minds so
much that it makes poor shows so I do
Wonder maybe when the new people in at
Disney and you know like that there are
top people in there again I've looked
back and gone we've done it again we're
just going to get yelled at so just pull
it just it's actually going to hurt the
brand
and and I think that's why Batgirl got
pulled because I think
um zazlav went in and he went actually
this is good I know it's 80 million
dollars but if we release this it's
going to hurt us
so just don't release it
um how bad was Batgirl though compared
to things like Blue Beetle did they try
to lie to us they try to say this is the
greatest sci-fi movie ever made or great
superhero movie ever made there's enough
of flash which
they did it with I'm sorry they did that
with a Flash and I'm like if that James
Gunn generally thinks that's the best
superhero movie ever made the next 10
years at DC are going to be very painful
I I do think
The Flash would be looked at a lot the
the the CGI is pretty damn bad in a lot
of places and that does take you out of
it and the story's not necessarily great
and it kind of forgets a lot of its own
plot points especially eating calories
at a certain point
um yeah it doesn't bother but I feel
like if that would have come out before
across the spider verse
we would have a different take on it I
think that's just the take that I think
they're getting from a lot of those
people honestly I don't think so I think
it still would have been
um roundly pretty much hated because it
is actually
a pole film
the actors problems didn't help no the
actor being an annoying little [__] also
didn't help
and he's supposed to be annoying
and
um
and then he meets his twin who is or his
other version of himself who's more
annoying
and I'm saying dude if you're if a big
plot point of this film is that this
person is annoying even the annoying
person right so in the background of the
Justice League The Flash is actually at
that version of The Flash is actually
quite interesting because he's sort of
like comic relief but if the man die
he's just irritating it's abrasive it's
I don't know a better word for it it's
abhorently abrasive a bit where he loses
his power so he's then doing that I'm
just running really slowly I'm just like
oh [__] just just kill me now
um it's just bad so
I I think it would have looked been
looked upon better until across this
spider-verse came out because they
literally do the same thing good job
with it yeah so much better yeah but
that that concept I think it would have
it would have been a nice little
stepping stone to Across the spider
verse
did Good by just being first and blowing
our minds with that another thing now
the other problem was The Flash TV
series did it better
that anybody that loves this TV show
must be sitting through this watching on
I've seen this story they just did it
they even had Michael Keaton and they
did it in like squeezing before right
that's when it started yeah but um it
was so I mean it was just done better
yeah the cow did a better job CW but
that's funny
that is meant that is mental the CW dude
but I think actually
The Flash was their best show I think
for me I think it was just for not I
actually liked the arrow first as a
whole actually I quite liked it start I
I watched Arrow when it first came out I
quite liked it and it was amazing I was
watching four shows
I was watching Arrow Flash uh Legends of
tomorrow and Supergirl every week
Legends of tomorrow for me is where it
started to I started season one of
Legends of tomorrow I I will fight for
all the time because that was great
Leonard snart
at the end was that that was some good
TV and then season two it just it leans
into the silly it gunifies itself a
little bit for lack of a better term uh
the cwai Riders did better a little bit
howdy Niraj that's our editor graphic
designer
um you'll say Howdy and thank you to
Niraj while he's here uh he keeps me
going uh but is that why crater got
pulled after a few months to save money
I'm not familiar with crater I'm not not
sure
no but I can't think but yeah it
probably would have been all right uh is
this David Bailey asks is it the return
of Blockbuster and cable
I think it's a return of cable
I think it is I don't
I think it's the return of the
Blockbuster in a way but not necessarily
like Blockbusters I don't think it's
like the the company Blockbusters coming
back and the way it was in any shape or
form anytime soon
but the two biggest movies of the year
or the three biggest movies of the year
are tint pool films they're Barbie Super
Mario Bros and Oppenheimer are hit pole
Studio films they're not independent but
they feel a little more independent
because we're we're just stuck in the
superhero Zeitgeist and all these
different things
um
they feel a little bit more independent
which is nice I like that feeling but
it's weird because the studio tent pole
film should not feel more independent
and that just shows you where where
we've become as a society where our film
is and how our mindset I guess going
into film is is we want that spectacle
but now we're kind of tired of that
spectacle so we want like a
not a mid-tier spectacle that's not the
right way to say it but something that's
not going to be over the top all the
time
but just right like Barbie's not over
the top all the time just 85 of it
oppenheimer's not over the top all the
time just like in like 10 15 of it but
where those like percentage points hit
they hit harder yeah it's what Marvel
used to be brilliant sounds so great you
want her children I keep saying this
they just wandered up to silly but they
never crossed the line and then after
you know the last few films though
they're dancing all over the line and
making like they're flicking these at
the line it's just like Guardians yeah
it's just it's it's gone they've just
forgotten they've lost their motion they
forgot how to do it
um
destroyed their brand
no no I don't what what is
what is the Hollywood brand
I don't know it's ever changing I don't
think yeah I was gonna say Hollywood's
got a big problem right now because
entertainment was its industry
and now the rest of the world is doing
it better
it's you know and and these strikes I
honestly think a lot of the longer it
goes on
the quicker they're hastening their own
downfall
because the studios will just move out
of America
they just they just want
they'll just go elsewhere
and
they're just they're just hastening
their own decline if they're not careful
I think at the moment there's a there is
a really big argument don't get me wrong
and I support what they're doing the wga
and sag-aftra and I do support them
um but they do have to be considering
this is like in in Britain we used to
have a really strong car industry but
the um makes kept going to strike and
kept going on strike and in the end the
car manufacturers either fell apart
collapsed or they moved manufacturing
out to the UK and we basically then
didn't have a car manufacturing industry
for 20 years
we don't have a major British car brand
um we just don't have one it's it any
that we any that you know are owned by
somebody else we have a really good
Small industry but we do not have any
major
uh manufacturing our biggest car
manufacturer in this country is Nissan
you know so because they've got a big
Factory here that's what Hollywood are
really at risk of doing they're actually
risk of of cutting their own throats if
they're not careful because it's cheaper
and then a lot of the time easier to
produce this stuff abroad at the moment
they've still got the big Hollywood
actor is still a thing but even that's
not guaranteed
um
well
I scrolled up thinking this comment
would correlate a little bit more and it
does to a degree
and we can kind of make it correlate a
little bit more is is it possible that
YouTube reviewers are destroying shows
before it's released therefore the shows
have less viewers when in reality most
shows are Mindless entertainment
people are going to say yes I think
absolutely not the same to a degree to a
degree I think there's there's the
subsect of people that will probably do
that but I think a lot of the ways we
treat it it would be the same ways
after a football match American football
football everywhere else
afterwards
you watch the the post show you watch
what the the commenters thought about it
then most of the time if you're a dude
you're gonna go watch
a podcast about it and then another
podcast talking about the opposite kind
of point of view on it and then you're
gonna go watch Game Center on ESPN the
next day to tell you more about it we're
doing the same thing with movies I think
the more you do that the more eyes you
get to go see those movies
you know the nice thing about the
YouTube reviews when they're honest as
well
um is that and they're not they don't
have an agenda which a lot unfortunately
do have an agenda yeah is that when a
good film comes out that people aren't
watching they bring eyes to it and that
is the that is the positive the negative
is things like rings of power that there
was so much negativity thrown at it
before it came out
um that it harmed the show and it did it
harmed the show even if people either
people didn't watch it because they just
assumed it was going to be a worthwhile
of nonsense or they watched it with that
mindset
yes it's really negative I actually
think dial of Destiny was massively
harmed by YouTube and YouTubers
throw in a lot of negativity at it
because at the end of the day that film
even Crystal Skull had a good first
weekend
dial of Destiny didn't even have that
I think the flash had other problems but
YouTube didn't help
but there were other issues behind that
um the problem is there is that there
are YouTubers that have an agenda
against certain projects for certain
reasons and it does harm
um those projects
um but but like I say there are two
sides to that coin
because it can just as easily bring a
lot of a positive attention to projects
it wouldn't have done
the damn problem is that we've got far
too many YouTubers with an agenda that
have hundreds of thousands of
subscribers because they're right very
right wing or very left wing or one of
the other and I actually generally think
they don't a lot of the time believe
what they're actually saying
they could latch onto certain things and
then they just attach their agenda to it
and they go
yeah same thing does happen in gaming
okay I have two thoughts real quick
I've got to remember the first one
because I thought of the second one and
it blew the first one in my brain and
when I thought of the first one through
the second one out you know you know how
it works sometimes uh popcorn says was
it really the reviewers that tanked it
or to the Amazon marketing that made
everyone think the show would be [__] so
that question is kind of part of the
question I was going to ask is
with with I don't think dial Destiny
deserved it but do you think rings of
power deserved the hate of God because
they literally gave us I mean it looked
beautiful it is a beautiful show
but it's not a good show it's not
written well it's it's it's underwritten
underdeveloped brilliant I think it's
good show it's not brilliant it's too
slow it's something it's not as good as
it should have been for for that type of
material though
didn't deserve that type of hate be not
necessarily that type of hate but it
deserves at least some or a portion of
the hate because they're focused I
didn't think it deserved all over here
because a lot of people throwing hate at
it hadn't seen it so how can you hate
something you haven't seen yet
um and they were they were saying it was
going to be this going to be that before
they'd seen and that that really
irritated me
um
Amazon
the way they set it up and everything
they I think they knew [__] we're gonna
have to tell people who spent a billion
could on this
so instead of sort of trying to keep it
quiet they made it a big deal that
they'd spent this is going to be the
most expensive show I've ever made and
they they wore it like a badge of honor
and that was a mistake because we were
just going into a period of cost cutting
and where people all of a sudden were
starting to Pinch Penny pinch and I
think a lot of people were like and were
genuinely angry that why are you
spending this stupid amount of money on
this TV show this is ridiculous it's
more than you I know and and the whole
billion pounds is but dollar sort of
thing is is not quite accurate but
um but basically they you know they did
they brought like a bunch of money
if they'd have done that 10 years ago I
think people would have gone crazy and
people would have watched it just
because oh my God this is amazing how
you know they've spent all this money on
the show this is going to be you know
this must be amazing but at the time
they did it
people were starting to struggle
financially and it just I think it just
it just mixed up a bunch of hate
um and then unfortunately a bunch of
YouTubers
are latched on to things like
the elf that
um the dark you know the dark-skinned
elf and things
um who was one of the best parts of the
show at the end of the day I'm just
saying yeah and I mean even Lenny
Henry's character who those half foots
are supposed to be dark skinned and they
were throwing a lot of crap at that and
I'm just like a J.R Tonkin would have
hated this one of the family who knew
him think it's great so I love people
always say that and then I just this I
think the other day I was on Instagram
and one of the things that popped up was
like one of the little 1974 Hobbits
things the animated film Aragorn
straight up a Native American dude in
there he's like straight up like Apache
as can be like he's just like hey and
he's hugging Legolas who's like this
little fairy dude and it's just like
it's super funny he's like a little he
looks so much like more like elf-like in
that way it's so funny uh and then Here
Comes Aragorn straight up Apache Ranger
and it's just like I I'm pretty sure the
tolkien's signed off on this too you
know like I don't think they really the
storyline of The Lord of the Rings is
about Nations I mean it's about world of
one thing but it was about Nations
coming together
I'm not sure J.R Tolkien was a racist so
I know that I know yes I know the elves
are supposed to be Nordic and blah blah
blah but I you know
is
I don't think it's fair to extrapolate
that he probably would have quite liked
and he probably would have had more
color if he'd have written it today so I
don't think it's an unfair assumption to
say actually he'd have loved those
aspects of the show that a lot of people
are going toky would have he'll be
spinning in his grave you don't know
that so shut up
um and Galadriel
was is portrayed as she's written
she's not supposed to be
the the most likable person on the
planet but she is supposed to be the
finest Warrior and all this sort of
thing she's supposed to be a bit of a
superhero she wasn't the finest Warrior
that they leaned a little too much into
the warrior aspect it's my only thing I
actually loved Clark loved by the other
elves because of all that sort of thing
that wasn't she so she was supposed to
be a bit of a mythical
Elven being sort of thing and that's
that comes from a reason so I think they
leaned into what was actually written
so you know but everyone just went
because and I just don't think I I can't
never think that if that character that
opinionists people wouldn't have
complained about it but she's got boobs
and she's a woman so she's uh Mary Sue
and that just winds me up yeah
but
it's not that's not what happened you
know uh it's just like that but okay a
lot of people though have thoughtful
reasons for this hate
and other people are just bigots and
they don't see they don't think Beyond
it's a woman and she's just doing a
backflip
um women can't do that and that's how
they think it's like I'm pretty sure
they can do backflips easier a lot
smaller
a lot of people nighttime girl can't do
that
it's irrelevant
Point that's almost the point of it like
she can't do that so she had to find a
way to and and it takes her an hour and
a half two hours technically a few days
worth in the actual show or the movie
but like two days worth in the movie but
it it doesn't happen immediately there's
there's a struggle that has to to get
her there that's yeah
I'm kind of with you
um I was awesome I love Xena
um
let's eat it for another night yeah I
need to go eat I do need to eat yeah and
I'm live again in like an hour and a
half talking about Star Trek I need to
go yeah
prepared
yeah but but I think we've covered this
and explained why these things are going
and it's not to do with residuals it's
to do with
other costs but it is a cost cutting
measure yeah streaming services have a
massively overspent and they have
screwed themselves royally
y'all should check out this article
though it is a good article
um collider collider always puts out
some good stuff
I'm a fan of some Collider uh but
hopefully I need to check if I got those
IMAX tickets to hunting and Venice from
collider I'm I'm hoping
I think I need to see what's on I need
to go watch equalizer through the
weekend excellent yeah what or go see
bottoms because that I swear that was
the funniest I I know it sounds so crazy
and weird but is the
you'll just it was the funniest thing
I'd seen in the entire year and there
have been better comedy movies this year
than we've had in the last decade
yeah and that was the funniest thing I
will keep an eye open on it but I'm
gonna go to equalizer all right it's a
cinema movie come on of course of course
but before you go yes sir before I jump
in and start reading off all these
things for Tiff and and what's happening
in the Toronto International Film
Festival what what can we look forward
to there's a Nick Cage movie that looks
pretty good
um
the best
episode
of the the best live-action Star Wars
we've gotten since George Lucas had his
hands on Star Wars happened last night
Ashoka was that good 34 minutes of
perfectness perfectness
Maureen when that big hawky thing came
in and swallowed a child and there's
some reason that child survived for days
while they were searching for him
that doesn't hold a candle that doesn't
hold a candle
not just one two
and they're great the first episode
three legitimately that will aggravate
you it's the shortest episode 31 minutes
the writing pisses me off in a couple
different spots
in episode four
just right I will start watching Ashoka
tomorrow and we will discuss it on the
live on Sunday and if it's bad I'm
getting a flight and I will come and
kick you in the nuts it's okay you can
do it I'll still cook your barbecue
afterwards and then we'll watch the next
episode of Ahsoka
this is [__] as well kick your nuts
again
give it a go I will give I will push
through the first three episodes then
okay you'll love it you might have to
watch the second episode again
distracted just watch two and three
because those are short get those out
the way four wow I I had to push through
the first series Amanda I had to push
through the first two three episodes and
then and I ended up loving it and
um maybe I was a bit quick but I will I
will give it another go and I love the
actress that's playing it and I'd love
to know everything she's ever done she
she does a lot more than just stand
there like this
in the fourth episode which is great
because that's the only thing she's done
for three episodes until episode four
and there's a few leaps of logic in the
first couple of episodes that I'll [__]
about on Sunday but um just a couple
but they make up more than this which is
so good well you've won me over sir
okay right guys I I am going to be back
in an hour with Mike off the solar one
podcast we're going to be talking about
Star Trek
um it was on for yesterday I made a
mistake
so it's been re-edited but when you put
a stream on and then you change the time
YouTube doesn't like it
um so but if it it is on it'll be
tonight it'll be 9pm we're looking at
Classic Star Trek episodes I'm asking
the question as any new track
had actually any classic episodes
and that I'm struggling or is it all too
woke
[Laughter]
um so we will be back on at 9 00 PM with
with Mike from Solomon podcast so Harris
thank you very much Matt you've dug into
my course meeting time though by 11
minutes you bastard yeah well go eat go
eat real quick and uh we'll be talking
some Toronto International Film Festival
for the next few minutes and then I'll
probably get out of here too but we got
another 15 20 and it's probably
actually go over to M Cube if you if you
want to watch the end and then we'll end
the stream on Sidetrack for now but um
go over to M cubed and make sure you
tell your friends
to go and watch the the young American
come on
I will end on Sidetrack now so guys been
amazing thank you very much we will see
you next Wednesday
bye-bye oh yeah
all right all right all right let me see
if I can share